parliament stepped up efforts to help
boost ukraine's economy as meps endorsed
a proposal to remove 98 of custom duties
that would save exporters and
manufacturers at 487 million euros a
year at a time when russia is blocking
ukrainian imports the help couldn't come
fast enough but for the mepu draft of
the report ukraine will quickly need to
sign up to a free trade agreement with
the eu once these temporary measures of
assistance run out these measures which
are voted today are temporary measures
they should last not longer than until
the 1st of november why
because we expect that after the
presidential elections in ukraine in may
in june we will be able to sign this
association agreement
it's hoped that revising the rules and
clinical trials will cut the red tape
and put an end to trend that has seen
trials outsourced to china and asia one
of the main changes is that academics
and big pharmaceuticals will have to
upload the results of all trials onto a
public database but we've made it clear
that once they've asked for market
authorisation for a medicine it's no
longer commercially confidential that
means that we'll get the details of all
trials published whether they're
successful or whether they're not
successful and that's really important
for good medicine and it's good for
people's trust in medicine as well
it's become the norm to use debit or
credit cards to make online payments for
goods or services cashless transactions
are fast and easy but costly and fees
vary across member states with elections
around the corner another dossier that's
been pushed through before the end of
the parliamentary term will cap credit
card fees to 0.3 percent and debit card
transactions to 0.2 percent it was
always a good deal between well the more
or less the two
credit card companies mastercard visa
and the banks
so those were the two deciding on those
fees so they were far higher than needed
so of course the banks will now have
less of an income on that side but but
it was an income that was paid by all
the consumers who had no clue they were
paying for it the new rules could save
retailers 10 billion euros a year in
fees from bank